all eyes are on circa and it's grand
opening
circa has many attributes including the
world's largest sports book
and that's where rocky is live to tell
us more about this three-story stadium
style book hey rocky
hey you guys yeah it is so exciting
obviously no one's here yet it opens at
midnight but it's already a party you
hear the music going
and have you ever seen a sports book
with an escalator
in it okay that's how big this thing is
and you said story stadium style three
story stadium style so
let me explain let me break it down for
you let's start at the dugout
okay that's this is how the space is
broken down the dugout first
with these brown comfortable chairs it's
vip single seat cushion chairs right in
front of the
million pixel high death screen do you
see that that is incredible
and then the legends club that's 18 blue
recliners right there also very
comfortable seating
and then the champions club booth for
larger groups if you're coming in you
know social distance with your mascot of
course
and then the circle club which has
luxury stadium or luxury
round tables and as you can see if you
zoom in you can see the little
newspaper clippings on the table it's
major vetting stories dating back 40
years
so you get a little you know history
lesson while you while you sport
while you've been on your sports and of
course like i mentioned it opens at
midnight so come down
place your best we're in the middle of
football season grab baseball
and be a part of vegas history okay why
not and then if you look over here to
this side
you've got victory burgers so of course
you can eat as well because who doesn't
want a burger while they're watching
sports
and just fyi later up in the shows that
before
the five and the six i know ted will be
showing off the stadium swim which is
let me get this right here fifteen
thousand square feet
of what space i don't know what that
means but you definitely should tune in
to find out
i'll send it back to you guys thank you
so much rocky it looks absolutely
incredible
by the way we're told circa is going to
provide up to 1500 total jobs by the end
of the year
when the hotel tower opens great